kenosha wisconsin which is nervously
awaiting a verdict in the kyle
rittenhouse trial some demonstrators
have already gathered around the
courthouse where deliberations continue
this morning the 18 year old is accused
of killing two people and wounding a
third last year rittenhouse claims it
was all self-defense the prosecution
says otherwise and our nancy chen is
monitoring it all in kenosha for us
again this morning nancy good morning
tony good morning to you the jury left
yesterday with no sign of a verdict more
than eight hours after starting
deliberations that did include asking
the judge for additional copies of their
instructions as they weigh five charges
against kyle rittenhouse
no
justice
protesters for and against a guilty
verdict gathered outside the kenosha
courthouse yesterday
[Applause]
standing by in case of any unrest are
500 wisconsin national guard members who
are stationed outside the city
[Music]
[Applause]
that divide comes after two weeks of
testimony and arguments portraying
written house as an instigator or
someone in fear for his life
and an unusual ending that allowed
rittenhouse to select the jury from a
lottery drum folks you can retire to
consider your verdicts the jury made of
seven women and five men all white
except for one person are now
deliberating rittenhouse's fate there is
no lawyer who could possibly say
that long deliberations versus short
deliberations favor one side or the
other at some point reach a consensus
and as these deliberations do continue
the jury is not being sequestered the
same policy they followed throughout the
trial they will gather here soon for a
second day of deliberations tony
all right nancy thank you very much